je sais comment jouer à ce jeu là comme
dans la vie il faut prévoir les qu il ne
s'agit pas de savoir où on en est mais
de savoir où on en sera dans dix co ou
dix ans
une crise cardiaque
comment ça peut lui arriver là bas est
en meilleure forme qu'il ne te sourit
il ya en fait une chose dont nous devons
discuter qu'est ce que ça fait ton père
a laissé un portois
[Musique]
et toi seul est ce qu'une seule fille
sur terre connaît vraiment son père
montre moi ton visage
lauren elisabeth mono t'es pas comme lui
mon avis tu meilleur qu'il ne l'a jamais
qu'ils vont j'aime bien penser que je
suis un membre de la famille après
toutes ces années
est ce que papa a fait des ennemis dont
je devrais être informé tu sais bien que
c'était pas une personne c'est notre
famille je jetterai son corps dans la
rivière dicte avait pas peur la vérité
rire il ya des secrets que j'emporterais
dans ma tendre
si tu m'apportes que je t'ai demandé je
te promets de tout raconter
est ce que vous vous moquez de moi
est ce que mon père nous cacher un autre
chauffard et une avocate un banquier un
politicien a qui te parle est la pire
des trinités ton père n'avait pas le
droit de faire ce qu'il a fait est
sacrée femme
le projet ria du tournoi au mariage
mais une fois que je t'aurais tout dit
tu connaîtras la vérité
et là je sais que tu me libère
la vérité doit rester en tête
[Musique]